the game has already been played umpteen times
from norway so you see are interesting
players who have absolutely no theory
but still
play on again after really well
bishop b5 yes of course i do
n't have a real recipe ready now
36 maybe
but i can also jumper the 15 that
I then sit out like a somewhat strange c3
jan o
sid dpa sid consistently out
so the other question is whether I
might
still take it then I have the 5
that offer but quickly
so I can even
accept
stripes
well ok I understand the trick
hofheim
yes then of course i will be
called
but maybe there is
still some
way to
take advantage of it right now
i could do something like the five of you
yes good he has two minutes
before
oh yes ok
so
thinks he wants windows 53  make
good
exchanges are not really in
my interest right now but
i think a bit about the badly
shrunken thinking time
would like to simplify a little well that's
how it works 7 yes it is of course a very
ugly position
which probably
just means good reference
yes i can  now besides but then
I would have sold myself well at the top
I think at least
yes that is of course right because of
course it says in the that is
not exactly nice either
yes if he plays it clean now
I probably won't get much
more chances
like
c4b
I got a bit of activity with it but I swim 5 the
pawns are all
weak or gone
then he too is a bit
weak actually in comparison
maybe he has
let the air in but now that you could
definitely play it stronger
I am  still not enthusiastic but
that leverages but what if I
now moment what if I take here now
and then
don't take c3 wrong anyway
so c3
yeah that's all a
bit off the beaten track
I still have two
unbelievably the double pawn in front of me  has
made a career
with the admittedly clumsy idea
china the 1 or just jumper 2 and
conversion so i
actually thought he could 15r five runners the
eight or
it the exaggerated
let's run away from here so now he can
think that okay
but  where is he going now with the
runner
he can't do anything want to put down tomi
jumper two each so my idea it
now c5 to open the box completely
then do the 1
yes
and very lonely
yes even fight
interesting how he has the right
moment  missed
that it was definitely totally won
references but suddenly
the zebau really started rolling